[Music]
welcome to the makeup and hairstyling
bake off for the 93rd academy awards
let's begin with the basics our
definition of makeup refers to any
change in the appearance of a
performer's face
head or body created by the application
of cosmetics
three-dimensional materials prosthetic
appliances
or facial hair applied directly to the
performer's face
head or body hair styling refers to any
change in the appearance of a performer
through hair styling wigs or hair pieces
applied directly to the perfume all of
the artists work is outstanding
and we offer our congratulations to them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
films like that have so many challenges
especially with all those elaborate
hairstyles and locations
and costumes and different people and
different elements
can you share with us some of your
biggest challenges that you faced on a
day-to-day basis
every change we had to do was basically
done on set
um or adjacent to the set in a tiny tent
which was quite tricky due to the fact
that we were using muscle
tongs and a small oven to heat them in
so that was against us give me your name
come on he's my call old boy yeah a
couple other little [ __ ]
that mccall boy had an idea die
loneliness will you give him some
ice they're professionals and they've
worn prosthetics before so
they didn't want to waste any time and
they wanted to get into
being mama and bev i did a lot of hand
painting though because i didn't want it
to be too caricature um
on either of them and so um i kind of
did a lot of just hand painting on
bringing out more of the sun damage and
more of the lines and
a lot of the aging around the eyes and
deep circles what the hell happened to
tell this man who i am better get him
straight all this man who we messing
with
could you talk about the steps you came
up with for the design of this character
the first thing i needed to do was kind
of do a really broad research onto
what was it like to be in 1920s america
what was available for women in 1920s
america
was there anything available to women of
color i had to cast a really wide net to
kind of set
the socioeconomic to build this
character i
i needed to know what her perimeters
were all kinds of different things that
had nothing to do with
uh the character itself but more so the
world that she lived in
obviously the movie is in black and
white which which you know uh
creates a whole bunch of challenges and
specifics but will you talk about what
uh you found was the the difference in
how you approach things with with
shooting black and white versus color
shooting in black and white is really
shooting in gray so
we had to retrain our eyes and everyone
had to do it
david fincher the director the dp the
costume designer
the set decorator we had to find
um tones in those colors
that we could look at he could look at
that the actors could look at in person
and it wouldn't be a shock
uh when you started this project for for
the creation
of all your characters because there's
certainly a lot of different things i'm
just curious what
what you were referencing the project
was was a real passion project for the
director
very passionate that we stick to the uh
flavor of the um original illustrations
for the collodi
uh book set it in the period uh
and in in tuscany in a sort of poor
rural area and he wanted to keep the
grittiness and the grunginess of all the
characters you know
especially the sort of cat and the the
fox characters are these really grubby
guys that live in poverty that work has
delighted
and transported us into the world of
storytelling
in frankly a year where we could all do
with escaping into the world of stories
beyond ourselves
and may we all enjoy celebrating oscar
at the academy awards this april 25th
on abc